[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to reboot
GameSpot's opinion editorial show I'm
Mike McCarty and I'm Jake Decker
and last week we published a video about
injustice - and how I think it does a
lot of things that pulled me into a
genre that I'm not super familiar with
and I've always found pretty
impenetrable I think that the game uses
accessibility in a lot of good ways and
if you want to go check out that video
from last week go do that now and then
come back and you can get into our Q&A
with us this is one of our off week
episodes so we're just going to kind of
answer YouTube comments I usually do
like Twitter replies as well but we
didn't get as many questions via Twitter
this week and then as always we'll tease
our next episode so we might as well
just jump right into the questions sure
do me to read the first one yeah go all
right first question is wade d McGinnis
from youtube and he says I don't think
accessibility strictly means dumbing
down a game give players more options to
work with it's up to them to choose to
use them it's no different than having a
difficulty slider for a title so I think
the first thing that jumps out at me is
how much is difficulty slider now this
video focused on injustice and yes there
is difficulty slider but I think with
fighting games difficulty is one thing
but then understanding the game is a
whole nother thing
yeah and justice too specifically
between you know meter burns the wager
system the clash system super moves air
escapes and just to name a few of the
myriad things that this game does
differently than a lot of fighting games
yeah it's it's learning all these
different systems and also how to use
them because then you get into you know
like online modes or you know PvP stuff
and it's just absolutely it's just
absolute chaos when you're trying to
figure out how to use these when you're
fighting against an opponent who's
clearly better at fighting games in you
and it's tougher to introduce new
gameplay elements or would Wade say
enemy variety or difficulty sliders to a
game without sacrificing the balance and
in fighting games balance is everything
right now I know Deadshot's kind of seen
as the cheap character and justice - I'm
sure they live from at some point maybe
but yeah I think it's just tough to
introduce new things for people who want
more in the game without you know
keeping that balance yeah
yeah then that's done I think one thing
we both agree on it was kind of the
whole point of the video was
accessibility he says I don't think
accessibility strictly means dumbing
down a game and I think yeah that was
the point of this video rather than the
like accessibility doesn't mean making
like I used to gameplay from fable 3
which is a game that I felt really
dumbed down the RPG elements of previous
games and within justice it did a good
job of guiding you into all those
different tactics and abilities and
mechanics that you were just talking
about rather than cutting them
completely or making them one button
presses or whatever yeah Wade McGinnis
thanks so much for YouTube's comment mr.
snake cake that's a rad man I hate
snakes and I like cakes
how does loot equal accessibility or
your DNA Jones I'm not the only person
who doesn't like snakes outside of
fictional archaeologists mr. snake cake
on YouTube how does a lute equal
accessibility the word you're looking
for is carrot on a stick and justice
needs to incorporate something like the
missions from guilty gear Revelator so
you can actually learn stuff in game
I think the gear was one part of why I
said the game is accessible I think the
multiverse is actually helps a lot with
that because you can stick at your own
difficulty level if you want to keep
earning loot with the AI difficulty bars
and then if you want to fight harder
ones you can take your level 20
character into this 8 tier
5 star AI difficulty battle the gear I
think does make it accessible though
because I think people who are used to
fighting games having this you know
apparently static kind of structure
right you get into it you learn these
there's these you know 20 characters to
learn and then outside of that the
people who aren't super into fighting
games might not find as many incentives
to play outside of just learning which
learning a game is one of the most
rewarding things in my opinion but I
don't ever have a time to learn
something like I want to play Tekken 7
but I'm not so sure that I'll be able to
keep working for that intangible skill
increase as opposed to seeing the gear
and injustice is great incentive the
multiverse allowing me to just play how
I want
the story mode itself like any fighting
game that has a story mode just kind of
you know you can get through without
knowing too many fighting game skills
but I think this game is just a
confluence of so many things that
actually invited me in that it actually
encouraged me to keep learning it like I
have three characters that I know really
well Green Arrow Aquaman and Robin and I
like those three and those are kind of
my mains but I want to keep learning new
characters because of those things I
mentioned yeah and I don't think loot is
necessarily the reason like I don't
think loot is what makes this game
accessible I think the loot is what
makes it it gives me more of an
incentive to learn these different
mechanics and like what you said the
multiverse like sure I play the
multiverse that's how I learn new things
but the fact that I'm doing this
learning new things and getting that
little bit of loot is is like a nice
icing on the cake on the snake cake on
the snake cake Thank You mr. snake cake
mr. snake king uh this one is from Haku
PSO and he is from YouTube YouTube
California I think Capcom has also done
a great job with accessibility in the
recent month Monster Hunter games what
they did right was lower the initial bar
so that players could stick with it long
enough to see if Monster Hunter was
something they might enjoy long term
however later in the game the series
signature difficulty that fans crave
still lies and wait the result is
Monster Hunter games that are selling
better in the West and chant and the
challenge is still there for the vets I
agree with this I like Monster I've
played a couple I've dabbled in Monster
Hunter games I played a couple on the
3ds and wall I don't think those games
are for me I definitely can understand
why people get so into them and they
were definitely easy to pick up when I
got I think Monster Hunter for
generations is the one with for the 3ds
I think yes for the new 3d or the but
most recent games yeah yeah yeah no not
the most recent game the one before that
in a monster hunter 4 ok yeah ok
but anyway that game in particular I got
because I want to play with friends and
I had a great time playing with friends
and I could definitely see myself
getting really into it from there
however I kind of lost interest but I
think Monster Hunter games are
definitely a good comparison for this
yeah and that's probably like the
definition of good accessibility rather
than taking out that some of the depth
and kind of spreading it out to make it
more accessible to everyone and then
kind of leaving veterans like Haku said
in the dust I maintain that depth so the
veterans who know what's going on can
keep playing in the late game but those
new people who are coming in can learn
the game right off the bat or at least
after a few hours as opposed to like 30
and know whether they want to keep going
and I think that's like like I said the
definition of good accessibility I think
injustice to does that really well I
think it is going to make me in the long
term an injustice to veteran but right
now I'm still a newcomer but I'm really
thrilled to keep learning all these
things it's about that time
to tease our next episode
we are aware that last time we did this
we did not actually end up talking about
pray and what were we talking about we
were going to do side quests but the
side questions Jake is actually gonna I
think you're using as your own side
project maybe no pun intended but yeah
we had to pivot last minute and then I
ended up falling in love with injustice
two out of nowhere and also we were
going to talk about pray but I'm working
on my own side project that has a lot
about pray in it keep it out for that
but next week we will stick to this as
far as I know Red Dead Redemption - just
got delayed so we are going to use that
as an opportunity I've been speaking to
a few developers over the past few
months when we interview them for videos
about delayed games and I think it's a
little more common knowledge now that
delaying games is not a bad thing at all
but after Mass Effect Andromeda kind of
got rushed out and people who were
hoping to see Red Dead Redemption 2 in
September might be disappointed that
there is a delay we want to talk about
why delays are not always bad and when
they can be bad and when they can
actually be really beneficial because
right now it appears that Rockstar just
wants to take it
I'm but we're gonna dive more to that
and kind of talk about you know the
nature of game delays and business side
of it but we'll make it a little more
interesting and I'm making it sound now
I'm looking forward to this episode
because Red Dead is one of my favorite
games of all time even though it won't
be just about Red Dead most about Red
Dead Redemption - it's still something I
think a lot of us are very excited about
so I think it'll be timely and hopefully
interesting yeah looking forward to it
and as always get your YouTube comments
in on this episode or the past episode
go back and catch up if you're not right
now and we're looking forward to talking
about Red Dead Redemption - and game
delays next week we'll see you then
see
[Music]
you